In this video I'll show you formulation tools with which
half a to full grade can be better in your next English exam.
But brief disclaimer beforehand this list is of course not final.
Of course,
you need to take much much more initiative
yourself and deal with the topic comprehensively.
This here is just to serve you as a bit of assistance and I also
disappear immediately from the picture so that you can screenshot once.
And yes,
we're just going through this together now.
Your English exam is usually divided
into introduction main part and conclusion.
The introduction is usually a summerry in the main part then goes
correctly into the analysis and interpretation and in the end it's
just about the summary in what you discussed or found out more or
less in the summerry and in the main part The introductory sentence
up there for the samary should be hanging out from your ears but it
is simply beautifully formulated Take it over
and you will have no problems with it.
And now you see here these key points of the gasses the
Question if or presence the problem conflict of presence
aposibil View on And these are just nicer formulation tools.
Unlike Deal Swift or IZ A builds,
I would get so out of the habit if I were you.
That means that is simply your introductory sentence.
With these 3 um sentences for example Try an out can you introduce
your theme that means the summerry more Or less And this here are just
so 1 few keywords that you can pick up to not red on then sound
Instead of saying all the time and Van or the orchessace um the text
about or explains can you just bring in a few linguistic design tools
just to take care of so n bit of variety and be more concrete Because
it is also I do not want to say wrong to say he builds it or it goes
around or then it is said and then it is explained
There is just so much more done
And if you have written your summerry then it goes in the main part
and there you have to get used to always write so 1 transition sentence.
That means in the faiuring I will Erne live whatever so
you now know it goes from the summerry to the main part.
Now it depends entirely on how you discussed it in your class.
But for example with us it was also so that we were gladly seen that we
set up interpretive That means one says not only one will analyze now but
one gives already so n impression of it or respectively one puts this
interpretive hypothesis on which one then wants to prove in his analysis
in the following That means you say now already the author or whoever has
written that and that to make the reader feel that and that or to make the
reader doubt and to stimulate the reader to
think the and the atmosphere to create.
And you are supposed to prove this deuthungsropothesis
now with your interpretation with your analysis So and now?
11 little tip from Me uses this 3.
Step That is,
if you interpret 3 components must always be fulfilled That is,
there must be 1 document that is,
where do you get this information from or to?
Now where do you get that?
That is,
specify the line to which you refer and also quote specifically
From this line you refer here to 1 word on the whole line um which one?
What exact words do you want to address?
That is quoting That is that is simply welcome by teachers
and then you go to your interpretation That means we now
know where it says we know what exactly you are referring to.
And now you have to interpret the whole thing,
of course.
But this is always the very difficult part because I think
many of you do not even know what interpret in itself means.
The interpretation simply means that you explain what you have just taken from
this line and have now quoted with your own words again What is meant by this?
And I don't even think that's the problem,
but the next step that is intertwined in the interpretation.
That means you don't just explain what is meant but you put it in context.
You have to refer to something now when you interpret.
The question now is what am I referring to?
You can refer to many things You can refer to the atmosphere
that means you have explained something that is meant by it and
then you go into interpretation and say what is triggered by it.
Such an atmosphere and such is created by it or that
and that is triggered in the reader or the and the
graphic refers to that and that and is associated with it.
You have to contextualize the whole thing and do you know what the
beautiful thing about this interpretation hypothesis is that you set
up at the beginning Or if you are just looking for 1 patient for your
exam that means you want to concentrate more or less on the atmosphere
um then you would have to concentrate more or less on the laser
guidance And often it is also in the task what exactly you should
refer to That means in your interpretation you always go back to this
one where you say what you explain in your own words
and then you point to the atmosphere,
for example.
And so you always have your thread because you
do that with every single line you go through.
You know what I mean So you just have a
nice red thread because often I know that.
You don't even know what exactly am I supposed to interpret now?
Well,
that can just mean that and that.
And that can mean this and that.
But you don't have this beautiful structure.
You have this beautiful structure when you
refer to the same motif over and over again.
That is,
for example,
on the positive or negative atmosphere on one or the other laser guidance
on the 1 or other tunnel so that you always have an anchor to come back to.
And then we have the conclusion And it's not even that dramatic.
As I said,
you can take a picture of it right away,
so you can just summarize it again and I would
say that one to half of your exam column is enough.
That's all there is to it.
Just rough up the central motive or the main arguments of the text
how this had a gross effect on the atmosphere or on the laser guidance,
for example.
And then in the end,
how did it affect you?
Are you convinced?
Are you not convinced?
How do you feel?
Um do you feel that succeeded or not succeeded?
But as I said the most important thing I would say at the whole exam is
almost the summery That means that you have understood what it is about
which roughly the construction is that you have correctly grasped the
subject and you are in your analysis and interpretation in this 3rd exam.
Just step again and again to your hypothesis or to your
topic and that this is always the anchor where you come back.